today on the Matt Walsh show according
to the left I am a literal terrorist for
criticizing them and so are you actually
but this is a special kind of terrorism
that they just made up and I'll tell you
all about it also fauci declares himself
a symbol of integrity and Truth more
horrifying videos from Boston Children's
Hospital come to light describing the
sorts of Frankenstein gender affirmation
procedures they inflict on their
patients the EU makes another pitch for
eating bugs in our daily cancellation an
author takes heat for criticizing the
increasing Trend towards remote work but
is there some Merit to his criticisms
we'll discuss all of that and more today
on the Matt Walsh show
foreign
[Music]
I want to talk to you about American
financing America's home for Home Loans
because you know I really think that you
could benefit from one of their
10-minute mortgage reviews it's a free
no obligation conversation around your
current loan some of the other some of
your other debt and even buying a new
home as well whatever you want to talk
about with your salary-based mortgage
consultant you can talk about it with
them because they're focused on you not
a commission let them run the numbers
for you seeing if they can save you up
to a thousand dollars a month and if
they can they can move forward with a
new custom loan and start saving you
more money immediately American
financing is a family-owned company that
is family focused and they never charge
any upfront or hidden fees it's worth
the call to learn more uh and uh
especially these days when we're all
looking for ways to save money and uh
you can't you know you can't look to the
White House to help you out with that
you've got to take charge of yourself so
here's what you got to do call
866-569-4711 that's
866-569-4711 or visit
americanfinancing.net nmls 182334 nmls
consumer access
dot org
every few weeks or so the left will
stumble upon a new favorite word or
phrase that they will then proceed to
throw around with Reckless abandon until
in very short order we're all sick to
death of hearing a term that nobody was
saying seven minutes before the term
they uh the terms that they favor the
most and which have the greatest chance
of being adopted into the leftist
Lexicon is the term that accomplishes
two things
one it has to be useful in labeling and
dismissing their political opponents
that's the most important thing but two
it must also they Hope anyway make them
sound smart and they will of course then
use the term without explaining what
it's supposed to mean as if everybody
should already know
never mind that they themselves didn't
know what it meant until they dug the
term up a moment before or else simply
invented it out of whole cloth but then
they trotted out and used it and say
what you don't know what this means
it's a it's a kind of an intellectual
power play to use words that you know
the people that are hearing you won't
know what they mean they're gonna have
to go look it up and then that makes you
smarter
and that brings us to our new term of
the week it's very exciting
um it's one that's uh that you've never
heard before in your life and would have
never had any use for even if you did
hear it but which the left has recently
glommed onto the magic phrase is this
here it is
stochastic terrorism
now I discovered the crime of stochastic
terrorism just yesterday as I learned
simultaneously that I am guilty of it
there's nothing like learning about a
crime when you also learn that you have
done that crime it's a very terrible
thing
it seems that I have engaged in this
form of terrorism many times in my life
but especially this week after I along
with many other people called attention
to the Boston Children's Hospital's
practice of drugging sterilizing
castrating
and mutilating kids now I say that I
called attention to this and that you
know there are other conservatives
calling attention to it and we did but
we weren't the first ones actually
Boston's Children's Hospital Boston
Children's Hospital they're the ones who
called attention to it at first by
making videos about these procedures
that they conduct and then putting those
videos online
and then what some of us did is that we
took those videos and we said hey
everybody look at these videos isn't
that terrible
well that we have now learned is a form
of stochastic terrorism somebody named
Alejandra Caraballo a trans activist and
lawyer took to Twitter to trot out the
new favorite term and uh to also call
for my banishment from the platform
uh the Tweet says Twitter is just
sitting on their asses while Libs of
tick tock Matt Walsh Christopher rufo
and billboard Chris use this platform to
drive a stochastic terrorism campaign
against Boston Children's Hospital is it
going to take a provider getting killed
for them to act
another verified lib Pete Woods agreed
saying at this point Twitter absolutely
knows that the account in question uses
their platform to engage in stochastic
terrorism they're simply more concerned
about the backlash and the effect on
their stock prices if the account is
banned
that makes them a willing participant
that a doctor named Michael O'Brien with
pride flags and pronouns in his bio
joined in the chorus focusing his ire on
the libs of tick tock accounts
specifically he posted stochastic
terrorism is real terrorism Shia raichik
has mastered this and has been wielding
her wide influence against lgbtq
Americans for months so yes Shia
reichick is participating in domestic
terrorism
but it's not just Boston Children's
Hospital that has come under assault by
this still undefined sort of terrorism
another trans activist Aaron Reed
accused me yesterday of committing
stochastically terroristic acts against
Eli Ehrlich the trans drug dealer who
sends illegal prescription pills to
minors actually the true victim of my
terrorism is apparently Ehrlich School
University of California Santa Cruz
because I've encouraged people to reach
out to administrative officials there
and ask them why they haven't taken any
steps to investigate the drug dealing
operation being run by one of their PHD
candidates
in response to that Aaron tweeted
whatever you think about Eli Matt Walsh
releasing faculty info with a video
titled the trans militants Must Be
Stopped is stochastic terrorism violent
attacks on trans people teachers
libraries and lgbtq centers are at an
all-time high he knows what he's doing
now
we're going to Simply ignore the bid at
the end about how libraries and teachers
are suffering through a historic
epidemic of violent attacks libraries
really there's an epidemic of violent
attacks on libraries
now like most everything else the trans
activists say that's just pure fiction I
mean they just invent things constantly
because they have no interest in the
truth whatsoever and this is yet another
thing invented on the spot because it's
just it's just useful they would be
useful to the point if it were true
that there's a an epidemic of violence
against libraries and lgbtq centers
um and so we'll just say that there is
invented not unlike the term stochastic
terrorism itself
though there is some precedent for this
term way back on Sunday of this week
Daily Beast columnist wajahat Ali was
tweeting about this newly invented
Scourge he said more media outlets and
politicians need to start talking about
the gop's stochastic terrorism the
right-wing media's deliberate Fanning of
conspiracy theories and demonization is
radicalizing people to threaten violence
against law enforcement journalists
elected officials Etc oh now he's
concerned about violence against law
enforcement
not only that but he's worried about um
uh uh Reckless rhetoric that may put law
enforcement officers at risk
I mean never mind the fact that people
like wajahat Ali and everybody else on
the left have spent years claiming that
law enforcement by and large are a bunch
of um
you know white klansmen white
supremacists murderers prowling the
street hunting unarmed black men and
murdering them for sport like you know
that's that's not that's not
demonization of law enforcement not at
all
it's criticizing the FBI that's what
that's what's demonizing law enforcement
now a week before that
um a website called presswatch had an
article promoting the term with the
headline the phrase you're looking for
is stochastic terrorism and a week
before that the leftist rag Mother Jones
published an article accusing Donald
Trump of the crime of stochastic
terrorism so this is starting to pick up
steam is what I'm saying what does it
mean then
well the first answer is that it doesn't
really mean anything at all the second
is that it was apparently invented by
the left-wing blogosphere a few years
ago and now according to dictionary.com
anyway it means this
the public demonization of a person or
group resulting in the incitement of a
violent act which is statistically
probable but whose specifics cannot be
predicted
ah well now you see why they find this
concept so useful
it's easy to find a concept useful if
you made it up which they did
but you can see there
if you demonize someone or some group
then you're not only guilty of hate
speech which is an already ill-defined
concept
but you're now a terrorist
you're also guilty of incitement even if
you're not directly or indirectly
calling for any violence at all you
don't have to call for violence or say
anything about violence or or anything
like that to be guilty of incitement
as long as a violent act may be
considered statistically probable in
response to your statement then you're
guilty
well who decides the statistical
probability of future acts carried out
by people in response to what other
people have said well the blue check
mark trans activists on Twitter they
decide
and the media decides
and various other authority figures
now needless to say of course
this does not go the other way around
I am demonized and as I mentioned
yesterday defamed a thousand times a day
by these very same people but they're
not guilty of stochastic terrorism
against me for the simple reason that
they obviously didn't invent the concept
in order to hold themselves accountable
by it
they invented it to silence their
enemies and for no other reason and so
that's what they use it for
now
this brings us to the question I mean
whether we call it terrorism or
stochastic terrorism or any other kind
of terrorism
is it is it actually true that we're
demonizing Boston Children's Hospital
well well no
I mean it's not true that we're
demonizing Boston Children's Hospital
any more than we demonize the groomer
teachers by calling them groomers
because that's terrorism too by the way
now
well we we know for a long time the left
has been on this campaign well you're
not allowed to call anyone a groomer
that's that's hate speech
so it went from something that we said
to accurately describe what people were
doing and then they turned it into hate
speech and now they're escalating and
saying you know no it's actually
terrorism you are a terrorist
who should be shipped down to gitmo if
you use the word groomer
but
demonize
to actually demonize someone
what does that mean the dictionary
definition
to demonize someone is to falsely
portray them as wicked or evil that's
what demonize mean means
the key word there is falsely
see what we're doing is simply pointing
to what these people are doing calling
attention to it
and then criticizing it for reasons that
we are eager to lay out in as much
detail as anyone wants to hear
but what we've discovered about the left
is that the things that they're doing
and the things that they support
are so so hideously evil
that by simply pointing them out
by observing what they're doing by
pointing to it and saying look at what
these people are doing
is an act of terrorism
on our part
well here's an idea
Here's a thought that I would give to
the left
if you can be demonized by somebody
simply by them pointing out what you're
actually doing and saying
that that doesn't mean
that they're terrorists
it means that well
you're actually a demon
now let's get to our five headlines
the Consumer Price Index has reached yet
another 40-year high and the latest GDP
numbers confirmed the United States is
in a recession despite the fact that our
current Administration is trying to
redefine what recession means now is not
the time to have all your money in the
stock market or tied to the US dollar so
take action to protect your savings from
a highly turbulent economy Now by
diversifying at least some of your
investment into gold and silver from
Birch gold group text Walsh to 98 98 98
and Birch gold will send you a free
information information kit on how to
transition an IRA or eligible 401K into
an IRA in Precious Metals Birch gold
will even help you hold gold in a tax
sheltered account for decades investors
have relied on gold and silver as a
hedge against inflation now you can do
the same with an A plus rating with the
Better Business Bureau countless five
star reviews and thousands of satisfied
customers you can secure your future
with gold from Birch gold now text Walsh
to 989898 and get real help from Birch
gold today again text Walsh to 989898 to
claim your free no obligation in from
information kit on how to protect your
hard-earned savings with gold
all right we uh by the way
um I want to say thank you to Senator
Marsha Blackburn who hosted a screening
of what is a woman last night
down in uh in Franklin Tennessee and
there was a great turnout for that
apparently I was told that the screening
sold out in about 40 minutes and we
packed the whole place and uh it was
actually the first time that I've seen
what is a woman not the first time I've
seen it I mean I've seen you know is
through the editing process I probably
watch it 75 times but it's the first
time I saw it on a on a big screen and
it is a little bit
it's it's a it's it is a little bit
disconcerting at first to watch yourself
that up close and that large but um I
did uh I did appreciate it and uh and um
especially because
for so many people including many
Republicans when it comes to the issue
that what this woman deals with or the
film itself you know they kind of just
go running into the into the hills and
they want to talk about it uh Marsha
Blackburn hosted a screening about that
so of it you know hosted a screening of
the film instead so I really appreciate
that and if you haven't seen what is a
woman yet
um you don't have to wait around for a
screening you can just become a daily
wire member and uh watch it
right away and watch it as many times as
you want and tell all your friends about
it and I would very much urge you to do
that maybe we'll start with this
um Dr fauci I just want to play this
quickly because this is fauci displaying
his usual humility watch this
it's called the fauci effect which is
sort of like you know yes
trust me I'm I I don't get excited about
that
I mean it's nice but I mean it's it's
i i people go to medical school now
people are interested in science not
because of me because people most people
don't know me who I am my friends know
me my wife knows me but people don't
know me it's what I symbolize and what I
symbolize in a
in an era of the normalization of
untruths and lies and and all the things
you're seeing going on in society from
January 6th to everything else that goes
on people the craving for consistency
for integrity for truth and for people
caring about people
uh that is the uh he's he's mad if he's
mastered anything it's the um
I mean well he's Master two things his
master the art of getting paid for doing
a horrible job
and staying in the same position for for
decades uh you know many people in DC
have gotten pretty good at that so it's
nothing nothing impressive he's also
kind of mastered the art of the The
Humble brag so you know he could say
well I don't I prefer if people don't
say this I trust me I don't get excited
by this at all but uh but you know there
are there are people who say that I
symbolize truth justice Integrity virtue
there are people who say that I don't
get excited about I prefer if you didn't
say it but people are saying that about
me
this is uh you laugh at first but then
you realize that
you know only
a a
maniacally egocentric person could say
anything like that
and yet DC is full of people like this
and most of our so-called Public Health
authorities
are just like that
and while they take a lot of you know
they they give themselves credit for we
stand for Science and we stand for truth
I symbolize it if you imagine saying
that about yourself not just not just
giving your credit yourself credit for
for being honest which of course in
Fashion's case would not be true either
but to say that you are a symbol for
honesty
is just beyond imagination
um
but they give themselves credit for that
and also and also for courage
when obviously when it comes to the
so-called Public Health authorities
courage is the thing they lack the
absolute most
I mean they lack honesty they lack
integrity
but most of all they lack courage
because the public health crises that we
need them to speak out about
the things that are actually happening
in their world that they could do
something about
that's where they fall silent
for example bringing us back to Boston
Children's Hospital not you know far be
for me to continue my stochastic
terrorism campaign against a children's
hospital but um here's another video
which which by the way if if Dr fauci
as a as a supposed public health expert
and and according to him he's the guy we
all look to I mean he's standing he's a
symbol for for truth and Science and
integrity and courage
if in that position he were to stand up
and speak out against this against the
butchering and sterilizing of children
that would actually have an enormous
effect
he's done nothing good through his
entire worthless career
and now in his late 90s before he
shuffles off this Mortal coil uh
he he could actually do something
incredibly important
by taking a stand against this but he
won't do it
because he's a gutless worm he's a
coward
so here's yet another video that I want
to play for you because this is Boston
Children's Hospital they've they've gone
through and they're they're taking on
all their videos
that again they posted explaining the
procedures that they carry out
and here is one explaining how a
phalloplasty is done and no matter what
you hear from the so-called media fact
checkers
the fact is
that these procedures are in fact
carried out on minors
and here's uh boss Joseph hospital with
with uh some some kind of Jumpy happy
music in the background explaining what
the procedure is go ahead
aphaloplasty is a procedure to basically
create uh a penis or a phallus for an
individual who was born biological
female and who seeks transition to a
male gender the procedure is done with
plastic surgeons and urologists the
urologists manipulate the tissues in the
surrounding area to lengthen the urethra
and new scrotum is created and uh some
of the anatomical parts of the female
anatomy are removed the plastic surgeons
are in charge of creating a new tissue
that will ultimately meet the length and
urethra and the additional tissue that's
been moved to create the neophallus we
typically utilize tissue from Elsewhere
for example the forearm or the thigh is
used the plastic surgeons are also
responsible for
providing sensation by doing the nerve
cooperation so the new phallus will have
sensation and also responsible for
reestablishing the blood supply and also
to shape it in a way that appears more
physiologically and anatomically like a
natural one
now
that's what goes into the falloplast I
mean just to just to summarize the skin
is severed from the patient's arm
leaving them with horrific scarring
which you can see in in what is a woman
Scott Nugent shows what that looks like
um and even on screen it doesn't quite
you know you it captures it a little bit
but seeing it in person is a whole
different deal the arm is just I mean it
looks like it looks kind of what you'd
expect when you take someone's arm and
you de-sleeve it like you peel their
skin down like it's a sleeve and take it
off what do you think the arms will look
like after that that's what it looks
like and then they use that to uh craft
this
approximation of male genitalia
that's what phalloplasty is
and they can put all the music they
could put all the happy music you know
in the background that they want
there's no way to dress that up though
to make it sound like anything less than
a Frankenstein horror show which is what
it is
now Boston Children's Hospital has and I
believe that this is a new addition to
their website because now that they've
gone and they've started making some
changes to the website and saying oh
this and that procedure these are only
for people 18 plus
and so now anyway they say that that
procedure that you just heard is for
people 18 plus
does that make it better does that make
it okay
well consider two things first of all
the the ages the recommended ages for
all these procedures are precipitously
dropping okay so here's the latest from
post-millennials there's a confidential
document obtained by the post-millennial
from the leading transgender Health
Association shows they plan to lower the
recommended age for minors to obtain
cross-sex hormones that cause permanent
changes to the body and irreversible
chest genital and face surgeries this
Health Association is one the countless
doctors and hospitals rely on to create
their guidance for medicalized gender
transitions for minors and adults
um four and then we go through
um what how are they this is wpath of
course
what are the new ages that they're
recommending and yeah these are
recommendations but every as soon as
wpath says it every Medical Association
adopts it uh the American Academy of
Pediatrics all of them all the
children's hospitals they all just do
whatever wpath says when it comes to
so-called trans health so
for cross-sex hormones the recommended
minimum age has been lowered to 14 from
16 in the previous guidelines
the recommended age limit for double
mastectomies of healthy breasts has been
lowered to 15.
and for male miners seeking breast
augmentation 16 year old uh the the the
age limit has been lowered to 16. now
try to make sense of that let me try to
make sense of anything of any of this
but try to make sense of the idea
that according to wpath
you need to be older to get a breast
augmentation
than to get your breasts removed
now we shouldn't be doing these
procedures on minors at all
but you would think if anything it would
be reversed right because at least with
a breast augmentation you can to some
extent reverse that
if you chop the breasts off you cannot
reverse it that they're just gone
forever you've removed a body part it
can never get it back
well again if you're looking for common
sense when going through something like
this then you're just already barking up
the wrong tree the age for genital
surgeries such as hysterectomy and
vaginoplasty has been lowered to 17 a
year earlier than previous guidance
but
um
the recommended age for and this is so
pretty much all the the different uh
genital surgeries they now lowered to 17
except for phalloplasty which we just
heard about for that for now they're
saying oh you still you still need to be
18 for that
and so that is what the left is going to
latch on to and so well no you have to
be 18 for this
ignoring the fact that for pretty much
every single other form of Butchery
um they're doing it to minors
and also ignoring that first of all as I
as I said yesterday
even if they wait to 18 to do this to a
girl
they're they're still putting her on the
path to that way before that they're
setting the stage for it way before the
age of 18.
and also even leaving all that aside
you should not be I don't know how many
times I have to say it you shouldn't be
doing this to anyone
the idea that someone is
magically in the in the uh right frame
of mind to consent to a procedure like
this at 18 is absurd the very fact that
you want this kind of procedure done
shows that you're not in the right frame
of mind to consent to it
only someone of sound mind
should be a candidate for an
irreversible surgery but if you want a
procedure like that it is already
evidence that you are not of a sound
mind
if you're going into the doctor and
saying peel the skin off of my arm and
turn it into something that might look
sort of like a penis and attach it to my
uh you know to my to my crotch
if if you're saying that to a doctor
then it's clear evidence that there's
something going on inside your head
inside your mind that needs to be
treated
it's not your body that's the problem
all right
um
so the Pennsylvania Senate race is down
to John fetterman versus Dr Oz this is
what the voters in Pennsylvania this is
what they've decided they had other
options and other people especially on
the Republican side
and you may not have loved particularly
loved any of the options on the
Republican side but they did have other
options
and instead they decided you know what
we want to we want to boil this down to
John fetterman and Dr Oz Dr Oz who
doesn't even live in the state but he's
going to be one of our options the other
one is fetterman uh so how's that going
how's that race going well let's uh
check it out first we'll start with John
fetterman who recently had a stroke but
has decided to stay in the race
and um here's how he's doing
at his most recent campaign rally
and you can count
on us
to eliminate the filibuster if you
come out
and step with us
we will be able to stay and with you in
DC I gave away the lieutenant governor
governor in Pennsylvania the only
lieutenant governor in the history to do
that and let's let's get some stuff done
for America who would ever think that I
would be
the normal the normal one in the race
there yeah
now it's it's not even something you
want to laugh about because he had a
stroke and he's actually brain damaged
and uh and that's clearly coming through
in
his his speech there
and yet he's still in the race
and and uh and he might actually win
because that's the Democrat there and
the person that the Republicans have
decided to put up is Dr Oz and here's
how Dr Oz is doing in the race here's
the here's the the attack ad that Oz's
campaign put out against fetterman this
came out yesterday and I I don't think
I'm exaggerating when I say it it may
just be
you tell me what you think but it may
just be the worst
political attack ad
of all time I don't know but let's watch
now that John fetterman claims to be
recovering let's pull back his hoodie
and examine what's in his head
looks like he has some screws loose
what's this
fetterman wants to release one third of
all prisoners that's crazy
spend more tax dollars everything will
cost more that's nuts slow energy
production gas prices will Skyrocket
that's ridiculous
socialize medicine
get these crazy ideas
now it makes sense
better close it up
John fetterman is crazier than you think
uh yeah I think I think probably the
worst campaign attack out of all and
when I say worst I don't mean you know
the most vicious or worst of that way
not no not at all
it's just that that's that's what you're
going with this is like an ad this was
made by I don't know who he is working
on his campaign it must be some sort of
it's it's a group of Boomer Facebook
wine aunts who are who are working on
his campaign and that's what and that's
what they came up with
not to mention uh he's gonna be the most
radical most radical Senator that's no
probably not I mean John Federman I
don't claim to know a whole lot about
him uh but I don't think the issue is
that he's going to be the most radical
Democrat in D.C
now he does have to be a radical leftist
in order to be a viable candidate the
Democrats really don't
you know it's it's not possible to to
make it to DC as a Democrat without
adopting at least some of their most
radical positions but that's not that's
not exactly the primary issue with him
and this is but this is what again this
is what Republicans in Pennsylvania
decided that they wanted
this is the guide Dr Oz put that who
approved that campaign at the very least
approved it
uh he's the guy they're gonna put up
to represent them
doesn't live in the state but he's going
to represent them and their values
this is real late stage Empire type of
stuff
when you have prominent
uh Senate races that are boiled down to
Dr Oz the TV doctor on one side and the
guy with literal brain damage on the
other side
and of course Dr Oz's terrible Taste of
campaign ads is the least of our
problems when it comes to him
um we you know we could we we've we've
cycled through all the other problems
that he's you know talk about being a
radical leftist actually Dr Oz is by far
and away
more radically left than Fetter Menace
and I know that just based on the fact
that back in 2011 Dr Oz was promoting
the idea of trans kids and he was out
there you know advocating for Trans and
kids back in 2011.
he was doing it like five years before
it was popular
that's how ahead of the progressive
curve he was
and that on top of being an advocate for
gun control and all the rest of it
supporter of BLM everything
and Republicans in the state said yeah
he's our guy we want him
well you get what you deserve when you
make those kinds of choices as a voter I
would say all right uh this is from
d-n-y-u-z it says this is a story about
the rise in vasectomies
uh among men now I shouldn't really have
to clarify that it's vasectomies among
men because who else are going to get
them but you know how it is these days
uh it says in March Mike Pridgen a 28
year old comedian based in New Jersey
got a vasectomy and posted the process
on Tick Tock his doctor off camera could
be heard saying little pinch here and Mr
prison winces his eyes shut tight behind
his glasses bracing for pain
vasectomy a quick outpatient surgical
procedure that cuts the tubes that carry
sperm as one of the most reliable and
cost effective forms of contraception
available with almost none of the side
effects of complications of birth
control methods that are geared towards
women yet it has remained relatively
rare in the United States an estimated
500 000 men get the procedure each year
some survey suggests roughly five to six
percent of men between 18 and 45 have
gotten the procedure as opposed to
roughly 20 percent of women aged uh 15
to 49 who have gotten their tubes tied
but that might be starting to change and
interviews with the New York Times 10
urologists across the United States said
they've seen a notable uptick in
bookings for the procedure this summer
especially among younger child-free men
whose resolve to not reproduce appears
to have sharpened in the face of a
precarious economy worsening climate
change and a more restrictive Family
Planning landscape the weekend after the
Supreme Court decision in June to
overturn Roe v Wade Google reported that
searches for a vasectomy and are
vasectomies reversible surged it's still
unclear whether the increased interest
in vasectomies is a blip or the the
beginning of a long-term Trend that
could Foster greater acceptance of the
procedure then it goes on to give more
evidence that this is this is indeed a
longer term Trend and more and more men
are deciding to neuter themselves
uh willingly now the most concerning
thing about this
uh
is the rise especially in child quote
unquote Child free men getting this
procedure
and the first thing that's concerning is
just the term Child free
which of course by Design makes children
sound like some sort of disease
you say Child free like you might say
cancer free
and and this is done on purpose
because people that are quote Child free
they don't like to be called childless
because if you say childless it makes it
sound like they're missing something
and they don't want that so they'd
rather they'd rather they would rather
make children sound like cancer
then make their own situation sound Less
Pleasant to themselves
and so that's why there's been this
campaign among the childless to to say
no don't cause childless or Child free
or free of it we're free of the burden
but the other issue here is that you're
also
uh for for people who are
choosing to sterilize themselves
essentially
before they've even had kids
you're giving up on something that you
don't really understand and and this is
the Paradox is that you you can't really
understand Parenthood until you've
experienced it
and the reason for that is that it's
it's transformational
right it's one of those and there aren't
there aren't many things like this in
life
but having kids is one of them it's a
transformational moment
where you actually do transform it
becomes someone different than who you
were before
uh you know once you become a father
then you're a father you're just a
simply a different sort of person than
you were before you were a father
uh that's why I you know I like to say
that in the in the act of conception in
many ways it's not just one life that
comes into being but it's really sort of
three lives
you have the child that
that is conceived
but then you have the mother and the
father who are also sort of born in this
moment as well
that's why I know and I know this is the
case for a lot of parents when I
I look at my entire life before I got
married and had kids and I look at all
that and I I didn't have kids until I
was 25.
but I look at my whole life before that
as my childhood right up until I was 25.
and hardly even my own childhood it
feels like someone else's life entirely
sometimes
that's how foreign it is to me now
that's how much I've changed that's how
different my life is now
from the transformational effects
of
um you know accepting the responsibility
to be a parent
of embracing this vocation
so along with all the other problems
with people willingly sterilizing
themselves and choosing not to reproduce
and essentially giving up on human
civilization the process one of them is
that you are again giving up on
something that you you don't really know
what you're giving up you can't
understand you can't understand what
you're missing what you're losing
all right um here's one other thing you
know they really do want you to eat bugs
and that's not just a meme the European
commission tweeted this there's a long
thread advocating that uh we start
eating bugs more or at all you know as
if you were eating bugs at all in the
first place the European commission
tweeted a couple days ago whether a
snack or a food ingredient did you know
there are currently three insects
authorized in the EU novel Food House
Cricket yellow mealworm and migratory
Locus are the three types of insects
authorized as novel food in the EU
Market sounds delicious
so this is the good news if especially
if you live in Europe this has been uh
the migratory Locus is now uh it's it's
authorized as a novel food item
Chow Down have at it
um it says the FAO indicates that
insects are highly nutritious and
healthy food source insects contain high
fat protein vitamin fiber and mineral
content and facility can facilitate the
shift towards healthy and sustainable
diets novel food can only be authorized
if it does not pose any risk to human
health it must undergo a scientific
assessment prior to authorization to
ensure its safety
um the environmental benefits of rearing
insects for food are founded on one high
feed conversion efficiency of insects
less greenhouse gas emissions less use
of water and arable lands and the use of
insect-based bio-conversion for reducing
food waste
but they do note in their final tweet
that it's up to you to decide whether
you want to eat bugs or not
for now they don't add that but that is
we can understand that's in parentheses
for for now it's up to you whether you
want to eat bugs or not now I appreciate
the anti-bug eating movement
that's out there
um the people declaring that you know I
will not eat the bugs I will not live in
a pod and all that but I actually think
that the anti-bug heaters of which I am
of course one we should explain
why we don't want to eat bugs it seems
self-evident and in a way it is but
there are some deeper sorts of points
that I think that that we're making
about the human condition when we say we
don't want to eat bugs and I think those
points should be explained
but put another way The Advocates of bug
eating are pushing it for a reason and I
think we should be more clear about what
those reasons are
so I think there are a few reasons why
this is being pushed by the elites the
first and most obvious is that they want
to dehumanize us
right they want to treat us like cattle
or worse
this is a this is basically a control
mechanism
to slowly but surely take away the
little joys in life the the seemingly
little things that you enjoy take all
those things away
slowly sort of dehumanizing you
and reducing us all down to the lowest
common denominator
treating us all is exactly the same
and then So eventually they can ration
out our portion of crickets or whatever
for the day but I think maybe even at a
deeper level
the second point is to spread this myth
that the elites love that everything is
entirely subjective
so you know they say that our that our
taboos against bug eating are arbitrary
right not based in reason
there's no reason for it it's just it's
just a cultural thing that's all that's
the only reason we don't eat bugs
but that's not true there there are
reasons why humans are repulsed by
eating bugs and why usually only poor
and desperate people do eat bugs
because it is it is accurate to say that
in some cultures you know eating bugs is
common
but what you'll find is that in those
cultures they also don't have a lot of
food options and so they resort to it
because they have to
if you have other options the reasons
that people are pulsed by bugs is well
number one they carry disease they're
dirty
they objectively taste bad they have
little like Limbs and wings and all
kinds of physical features that makes
them unappetizing
so this is not an entirely subjective
judgment
it is true to say that that eating bugs
is objectively repulsive to human beings
but if you have to you can maybe get
over that um that gag reflex when it
comes to eating grasshoppers
but we don't have to and we shouldn't
have to and the third point is I read
this in a piece somewhere that made this
point I thought it was pretty smart is
that if you move away from meat right
and we just heard this in the Tweet
thread there actually you move away from
me you kill farms and Farmers typically
live and work and vote in red States
they typically are more conservative
so you you kill off all the Farms get
rid of all the farmers
and then you set up bug farms and the
great thing about a bug Farm is that you
could set it up anywhere and you can
especially set it up in urban
environments
so if we move to bugs being our primary
source of protein then that really means
that all the farming because now we're
not farming cows and chickens and
everything we need lots of space now
we're farming crickets and locusts and
ants or whatever else and you could just
do that in the middle of the city
so now farming moves over to the blue
States and the blue regions and they
take over
those are all the reasons why we
shouldn't have to eat bugs but again
really it actually is pretty
self-evident I don't think you need to
explain it it's just gross
let's get now to the comment section do
you know their name
they're the sweet baby game
Anne says have you noticed that every
one of those insane doctors speaking so
calmly and cheerfully about butchering
children is a woman talking in a baby
voice and channeling her inner
kindergarten teacher whether that's by
Design or there's more of that
personality type pushing this it's pure
evil now I certainly have noticed that
and that's something I also noticed when
filming uh what is a woman that this is
certainly not all but many of the of the
most vocal advocates
for all of this madness
are no they're not all women I mean many
of them are
but but almost all of them adopt this
kind of sing-songy baby talking sort of
voice
which in the end just makes it even
creepier and more disturbing
um Claudia says my daughter after school
said how is lgbtq possible when LGB is
about men and women liking men and women
and TQ won't say what a man or a woman
is
well your daughter by asking that
question has proven that she is more
perceptive than a great number of adults
because yeah that is a very good
question it's a very good point and um
what's the answer to it well the answer
is it's just it's incoherent
um and it's just the kind of incoherence
that we are supposed to not notice and
and we're supposed to not certainly not
talk about because if you do talk about
it if you do notice it then you are a
what is it against Scholastic Terror no
not Scholastic you're a stochastic
terrorist
I'm afraid to inform you Claudia that
your daughter is a terrorist for asking
that very question
um
Carla says Matt thank you for providing
contact information for officials at the
University of California at Santa Cruz I
want you to know that I've sent an email
to Chancellor Cynthia larive in which I
asked her what she planned to do about
Eli Ehrlich if she does not respond to
me I'll be willing to call her on the
phone please keep us up to date on this
matter I will keep you up to date we
gave out the contact information for the
chancellor of the school yesterday as
well as the dean of Graduate Studies
which again was a terrorist act on my
part and I was also Accused by of uh you
know of promoting harassment and all
these things but I have to remind
everyone that these are public officials
at a public university the contact
information I'm giving out is available
on their website it's contact
information that they have published and
I am pointing to it and saying here it
is
now
um from what I understand the voice the
voicemail box for both the chancellor
and Dean of Graduate Studies is now full
because people have called and uh
probably their email inboxes will be
full too soon too they still
are
trying to skate through this without
saying anything as I said yesterday
we're not going to allow that so the
next step is we're going to go through
and we're going to find other officials
at the school we're going to start
contacting them
and then it's going to be the Board of
Trustees and then we're looking at the
donors
and the reason that we're doing this is
because we need an answer from the
school and they have no right to not
give us one what are you going to do
about this problem
of having someone at your school
enrolled at your school who is who has
organized
you know a a black market illegal
prescription drug running operation
targeting minors
um
sweet baby gang for Life says I clearly
remember putting on pads in a football
uniform and running wind Sprints and
tackling and being tackled in a 90-plus
degree Heat at football practice when I
was a teen that was roughly 20 years ago
even still I was kind of fat for my age
it had to be climate change well that's
that's just your imagination the summer
did not exist when we were when we were
kids summer is a it's a new innovation
because of climate change
finally Brandon says this whole support
your child idea is directly
contradictory to honor thy parents
no I think actually the support your
child idea as it is
as it is uh promoted
by the trans activist it's not it's not
contradictory to honoring your parents
it's contradictory to supporting your
your children
so they are they're saying to support
your children in a way that actually
contradicts supporting your child
because the number one way or at least
you know one of the most important ways
that you can support your child
is to provide them with
stability and security and direction
that's what your child needs
stability security Direction
okay that is what your child desperately
needs
and when you just throw your kid to the
wolves or you abandon them to their
confusion and you say well I don't I
don't know you know you decide for
yourself what you are what your gender
is you just make it that's up to you
you are not giving them stability
security and Direction which is what
they need
every day the daily wire is expanding
and now so is our c-suite whatever that
is currently we have multiple executive
level openings on the team so if you're
looking for a high level job working
with top tier Talent keep listening to
be the next daily wire Chief previous
c-suite experience is required and a
background working within a mid-size
Media or subscription-based business is
crucial those roles are for Nashville
based positions only so no bathrobe and
slipper wearing telecommuters are
allowed here if this all matches your
actual experience and not some
make-believe lived experience then get
more details and apply today at
dailywire.com careers now let's get to
our daily cancellation
[Music]
the author Malcolm Gladwell got himself
canceled last week not by me I was in no
shape to be canceling anyone of course
but instead he was canceled by everyone
else from some remarks that he made on a
podcast now during the interview on this
podcast the conversation turned to the
dramatic rise in remote work
obviously when the world went insane and
shut itself down because of kovid there
was a sudden and seismic shift away from
the typical nine to five office
Arrangement and towards remote work and
that trend has not reversed itself
there's no reason to think that it will
reverse itself in the future according
to estimates by people who estimate this
kind of stuff 25 of all workers in
America will be working from home by the
end of this year that in a few more
years that number will be doubled and so
on and then eventually everybody will be
working from home this is very good news
for sweatpants manufacturers but it
doesn't seem like good news to Malcolm
Gladwell who provoked howls of mockery
derision and outrage by saying this
listen
as we Face the battle that all
organizations are facing now and getting
people back into the office that this
people it's really hard to explain this
core psychological truth which is
we want you to have a feeling of
belonging and to feel necessary we and
we wanted you to join our team and if
you're not here
it's really hard to do that it's not in
your best interest to work at home I
know it's a hassle to come to the office
but like you know if you work if you're
just sitting in your pajamas in your
bedroom is that the work life you want
to live right don't you want to feel
part of something
I mean it just I I it's I I'm really
getting very frustrated with the
inability of
people in positions of leadership to
explain this effectively to their
employees
that
um if we don't feel like we're part of
something important what's the point
it's not you're not just doing this to
get a if it's just a paycheck then
it's like then you what have you reduced
your life to right it has to be I don't
know this really is getting me kind of I
was in I was in Los Angeles
a few weeks ago and um
I was
pitching some idea to a studio I went to
two Studios
I won't name them both have these
beautiful gorgeous fancy offices of the
sorts you only see in LA right fantastic
you know sun is shining you go into the
parking lot and there are no cars there
and you go into these places where they
normally would have 500 people and there
are four now they say it's because of
covet it's not covered it's just they
they just did everyone's just decided
they want to work at home
and there it is the shocking statement
that made Malcolm Gladwell trend on
social media for several days and
provoked reams of think pieces all
agreeing that he's an idiot a fool a
maniac not to mention a big fat meanie
for suggesting that sitting around in
your pajamas and attending Zoom meetings
isn't the best path to human flourishing
the critics say that um office life you
know the critics of of Malcolm Gladwell
say that contrary to what he says office
life is oppressive and soul-destroying
and that staying at home is clearly the
better alternative they say that it's
good if people are no longer looking for
meaning or as Gladwell says belonging in
their jobs uh they accuse him of holding
on to this kind of antiquated Boomer
mentality which says that the primary
point and purpose of life is to punch in
and punch out and earn a paycheck they
say that's that's no good so we're we're
better off now some of the critics also
accuse Gladwell hypocrisy noting that
the author has over the years written
glowingly about how he enjoys working
from coffee shops instead of sitting at
a desk
um and uh you know that he himself has
worked from home uh and enjoyed it
now Gladwell has since explained that he
worked from home or from coffee shops as
a writer but he says that writing is a
somewhat unique profession in that
when it comes to actually putting the
words on the page there is very little
creative collaboration involved it is an
individual Pursuit as an author myself I
can attest that the collaboration if you
can call it that happens after you've
already written the thing and you hand
it over to editors and they collaborate
with you by picking your work apart for
months on end word by word as you
silently pledge to yourself that you'll
never make the mistake of writing
another book again
but according to Gladwell most jobs
don't work quite that way and so most
workers would benefit from being in an
office environment even if he as an
author did not
which seems like a reasonable
distinction to me but what do I know
so who's canceled here
well it's not Malcolm Gladwell his day
may come to be canceled but it's not
this day instead it's his attempted
cancellers who are canceled for two
reasons principally
first it's this
whether Gladwell is right or wrong
the point he's trying to make here isn't
unreasonable he's making a perfectly
Salient observation and raising
justifiable concerns even if he's
missing the Target by an inch or two in
one direction or the other there's no
reason why anything you heard In that
clip should elicit anything close to the
sort of reaction it received
moreover whether good or bad or some
combination the shift away from
in-person collaborative work and towards
remote work facilitated by video
conferences is a dramatic and
consequential change it's a change that
significantly impacts the way people
actually live their lives on a
day-to-day basis what this means is that
at a minimum if we're a rational and
intelligent people we would realize that
this is a change worth talking about and
we would be eager to consider the
pitfalls and listen to what the critics
have to say about it
but we're neither rational nor
intelligent which means that any opinion
slightly outside of the mainstream is
automatically treated as not only wrong
but totally insane and not worthy of
consideration
we have as a culture almost no ability
anymore to wrestle with ideas
instead we have one idea on a particular
subject and we will not engage any ideas
that challenge the one idea we will
instead scream at the challenging idea
and spit at it and spit at it and throw
things at it and stomp our feet until
the idea goes away
and because we have the memories and
attention spans of fruit flies we're
able to apply this strategy to even the
most seismic cultural and societal
shifts because once the shift takes
place
we immediately take for granted that
this change has happened and we decide
that we couldn't possibly do things
differently from how we just started
doing them five seconds ago
a person who advocates for a return to
the way we did things five seconds ago
is treated then like some sort of freak
from outer space or like a time traveler
from the ancient past
but by defending the merits of working
collaboratively in one physical space
with other people Gladwell is simply
articulating what has seemed obvious to
most everyone in the modern Industrial
Age
even if he's wrong there's nothing
radical or irrational about that
trying to create a society where people
stay on isolated Islands never coming
into physical contact with the people
they're ostensibly working with that's
what's radical it's a massive social
experiment and there's no way to know if
it will actually work out for the best
because Human Society has never tried
anything quite like this
and that brings us to the second point
and this is the thing that most people
as usual
seem to be overlooking
is it good for companies for employers
to have their employees scattered to the
wind connected only by email and zoom
calls well it seems pretty clear that
the answer is no it's not good for
employers
but Gladwell wasn't just talking about
what's good for companies he says it's
not good for the individual it won't
make you a happier a more fulfilled
person to forsake the office in favor of
your couch and your laptop he says that
remote work is bad for you as a person
because it deprives you of the
opportunity to feel like you're part of
something it takes meaning and purpose
out of your life he says now here
gladwell's critics are are seemingly on
a stronger footing as they can rightly
observe that you shouldn't be depending
on your nine to five for meaning and
purpose there are other better places to
find your sense of belonging in the
world if you work from home they say you
can invest more of yourself into your
family into your community you can
develop other Hobbies you can develop
other passions you can you know grow and
become a more well-rounded person you
could start doing other things you can
read more books you can maybe start a
vegetable garden or something you can
exercise more you could you can put your
job in its rightful place as a source of
income but not look to it for anything
more than that
for meaning and purpose and belonging
you can reach to deeper sources
and that's all true that can be a
benefit of working from home I work from
home for years okay so I know something
about that
but here's the important question
is that what most people are actually
doing so as we Splinter off and isolate
and live these increasingly remote and
fractured yet technologically dependent
lives working from home ordering meals
and ubereats having our groceries
delivered having everything else
delivered interacting with the world and
other people through screens primarily
Etc as we do this
are we in general using all of the extra
time that these conveniences afford US
to connect more deeply with our families
and to develop different skills and
passions and to pursue knowledge for its
own sake
the answer for most people is no not
even close most people just spend the
extra time staring at screens
the screens have enabled them to give
more of their lives to screens
working from home saves them from
wasting time on commutes and pointless
office gossip but all of the extra time
they're given is returned right back to
the same piece of technology that gave
it to them
indeed all the evidence available to us
tells us that for the most part though
we have a lot more time to connect with
our families and share meals and read
interesting books and do interesting
things we are not actually doing any of
those things more in fact we're doing
all of them far less than we ever have
the more free time we have the less we
accomplish with it that's the general
societal Trend here
in theory the shift towards working from
home could be an enormous boost for
human flourishing allowing us all to
re-center on what really matters in life
but in practice it's been mostly a boost
to the streaming services and social
media platforms that have been the
primary beneficiaries of all this
Surplus free time
so in theory
working from home could be in many ways
a superior Arrangement but in practice
most of those people really would be
better off in the office
and that was a very long and winding
road just to finally say that Malcolm
Gladwell is only half right which means
that his critics are also half right
but they're more annoying about it and
so today they are the ones who are
finally
canceled
and that'll do it for us today actually
no that won't do it the rest of the day
we're going to go to our new segment
that we just unveiled but you have to be
a member to watch it so we'll see you
over there
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]